Today in the world,
more people die from eating too much
than from eating too little for the
first time in history.
I think the last data for the World
Health Organization says that about 3
million people die each year from
obesity and related diseases compared to
1 million people that die from
starvation and malnutrition as a st time
for the first time in history,
more people dying from old age than from
infectious diseases and also for the
first time in history,
more people commit suicide each year
that the total number of death from war,
crime and terrorism put together,
which is very good news.
I'm
not the suicide bit front that affected.
Yes,
yes,
it's not.
It's suicides of went up.
It's the death from violence has gone
down today.
Let's say for the people here in this
room,
I think it's safe to say that Mcdonald's
and Coca Cola,
Paul's a far greater threat to your life
than al Qaeda and Islamic state.
The chance that
you,
the chance that you will die from eating
too much at Mcdonald's is about a
thousand times higher,
and this is not an exaggeration.
This is statistics,
it's about a thousand times higher than
the chance will be killed by some
Islamic state terrorism attack.